foreign
[Music]
thank you very much thanks everybody for
joining we're going to take a couple
minutes
to welcome people into the show
hi everyone
and uh well while we're doing that why
don't you introduce yourself to the fact
and let us know where you are coming
from
so we're all we're all here
hey Eve he's from Paris
welcome welcome I actually just made my
way up here hey one rape in Taiwan
awesome
quite late where you are thanks for
going in or early actually last time we
got Slovenia with Pavel
[Music]
oh insane
I had started from Toronto
film you're from Macedonia we have India
in the house Olivia that's really cool
Sam from the SF Bay Area
from Bangalore
all right
and London represents
welcome Anna welcome
today is going to be uh Philip and I uh
Julian is not going to be part of this
broadcast so we're gonna make it short
and sweet
trying to fit it all within 30 minutes
you
you find back from your day uh we'll
have many cool updates for you and then
an exciting demo from Philip the chapter
you want to stop the music
I will stop the music
yeah if it's hard to understand us if
the music is running yeah so all right
well then let's get started yeah hi
everyone I'm in welcome to hiking face
hugging cast V3 this is the third
episode of our live show about open
source AI so if this is your first
episode what's this thing uh we want
hugging cast to be a cross between a
podcast and a webinar we want to talk
about the latest and greatest
developments in a beautiful world of
Open Source Ai and we also want you to
walk away Having learned something
practical that you can apply in your
work so in each episode we'll have a
Hands-On demo
and today as I say we're going to try to
keep make our shortest show ever and
keep it at 30 minutes we're super
excited to take your questions during
the show so don't hesitate ask them
while we're speaking and we'll get them
we'll get to them when we have the time
or at the end of the show so I'm Jeff
pudia and the product team here at
hiking face and today I'm joined with my
co-conspirator Philip and fellow Caster
the hero of the demos
hey everyone
let's get started I'm going to turn on
the chat right here to see what's going
on
so first I want to give you some updates
about the latest and greatest happening
in hugging phase and first off uh two
great uh events and resources that you
can take advantage of we've recently
released a new free course to learn
everything about audio machine learning
and just yesterday we released the fifth
unit of the course that focuses on
automatic speech recognition so
transcription so it's a really really
cool unit
you can find all of our courses at
hikingface.to.cole learn let me flash
the page for you so you get a sense
there you go
so of course you may be familiar with
the Transformers course or NLP course we
recently published a deep reinforcement
learning course and now the audio course
so I invite you to check it out and the
latest units as I said ASR published
yesterday
so
um next I want to talk about
um a very cool event that's upcoming
that's going to be in just 10 days the
open source AI game jam and what this is
is an invitation for the community to
come together and build a great game
using machine learning in just one
weekend it's open to everyone it's free
for everyone so if building games is
your jam then subscribe to the hiking
face game Jam
and that's it for the uh for the uh
events
um next I want to tell you about some
exciting developments uh over the last
few weeks and maybe I'll start with
um with uh Clem rco Clemente long his
testimony in Washington DC to sort of
represent the voice of Open Source Ai
and open science and I thought that was
a very very cool
um very very cool testimony you can
watch uh the whole five minutes thing
actually have it over there let me play
you a quick clip from the excerpt that's
published on Twitter
maybe Jeff can you tell um the ones who
are not familiar you are talking about
what is it's about like what uh did Clem
do or like
yeah definitely so um there's currently
a lot of efforts from a Regulators
policy makers to make sense uh of uh Ai
and understand how to best
um uh regulate it how to best uh enable
it
um and as part of these efforts
um some of the key contributors uh to uh
AI have been invited by Congress to
provide testimonies and and share their
point of view and that was the object of
these uh this testimony
um and yeah maybe the best thing is to
just play you a couple seconds from it
first it's good to remember that most of
today's progress has been powered by
open science and open source like the
attention
okay I'm having bandwidth issues but I
think it was a really important
a really important testimony that
put forward everything that the
community has been building together and
bringing together uh to uh to uh uh to
to get us to where we are today right
all of the uh all of the great models
that uh the Transformers Library enables
you to access everything comes from this
collaboration of researchers uh data
scientists and machine learning
Engineers so it was great to have that
sort of voice be spoken in front of U.S
regulators and another Accolade and this
time around I don't have my uh my disco
ball so I can't bring on bring up the
prop uh but we were very excited I think
it was this week or last week to see
hiking face recognized as one of the top
uh 100 companies by time
um I think I have the link over there
there is the link and let me share with
you
the page on time
it's a really really uh cool profile and
a great a great honor not just for us
but for the whole Community that's been
uh contributing uh to collaborative AI
over 200 000 models now available in our
libraries and in the hiking phase hub
and uh last uh last company update and
this one is more relevant to uh to
businesses which is that we recently
received our sock 2 type 2 certification
what is this thing this is a stamp of
approval to show that our hosted
services so the Hub is compliant to the
highest standards of security which is
really important for uh our enterprise
Enterprise users so super excited about
this new certification which brings me
to the product updates and I have three
product updates for you today and the
first one is the Enterprise Hub and what
is the Enterprise Hub it's the same
hugging face Hub you know and love but
with additional sort of security
features like SSO for Access Control
like additional security features and
the ability to sort of manage your
billing
across your organization so if this is
something that Rings true for you then
do check out the Enterprise Hub you can
find it at huggingface.go slash
Enterprise cool so that's the first one
the second thing is
a new feature that just shipped in
spaces and it's the ability to set up
persistent storage for your spaces which
is really really cool for a lot of use
cases like data annotation or many
others and just like with Hardware
upgrades we make it super easy it's a
click through experience to upgrade and
get some persistent storage for your
spaces
um and last our product updates I want
to tell you about something that I'm
really excited about because it was the
number one uh requested features for
users of inference endpoints uh which is
uh an easy experience to take any model
on a hiking face Hub and then deploy it
on dedicated infrastructure just for you
and we just shipped uh automatic scale
to zero so you can find it within the
advanced configuration and then can set
up today to scale to zero if there is no
requests incoming within 15 minutes of
your endpoint so scale to zero that
means you're not paying for the
infrastructure anymore a great way to
save money if you have intermittent uh
sort of workloads
all right so that's for the product
updates
um and then I want to uh uh give a shout
out uh to our newest uh partner uh AMD
we announced uh just a week or so ago a
new exciting partnership between hiking
face and AMD to make it easy to use our
models our libraries with AMD platforms
and starting with AMD GPU so super
excited about that uh what you can
expect from us is a new open source
package to make this experience very
easy and a great support for our most
popular models on AMD platforms there
was actually a really really cool Event
in San Francisco I was lucky to be a
part of where Clem our CEO came on stage
to talk about our partnership uh Julian
Simon has a blog post on it if you want
to learn learn more about this
and that's for the updates uh the
updates I wanted to uh to show you today
I'm excited to uh to move to the most
exciting part of the of the show which
is the the live demo and maybe before we
get there
um I want to hear from you Philip about
like what's the latest and greatest in
the world of Open Source large language
models
yeah so I guess since the last time we
talked or did a hiking cast hiking cast
session a lot of
came out or got added to the to the open
source uh leaderboard and to the open
source source ecosystems yesterday
Salesforce has released their exchange
models which is uh let me open it
um which is a llama based model but it's
like a bit different to like the open
Llama reproduction since it was trained
on trained on 8000 meaning that you can
like now use all of the Llama ecosystem
is it llama CPP or uh local gpt4 or
whatever with the new xgen model and
have available a contact length of 8 000
meaning that future prompting or having
like conversational model got way way
easier and the model performs equally
well as the land well as the Llama I
think um yeah open Llama released their
14p model so a lot of a lot of new open
source llms keeps coming and I think we
we slowly but surely closing the Gap I
mean it's still a long way but of course
we know that like like we rather have
special certain use cases which are
cheaper to run and like this one super
powerful big model uh which I might I
might not have the gpus available g-ways
and then some things are interesting so
the team behind the open llm leaderboard
released a blog post last week um
talking about what's going on with the
open llm leaderboard and I think that
the most interesting part the most
interesting part about it is that people
asking okay why are we reporting uh
llama 65p
um or why are we reporting different
values then the meta team has reported
in their paper for the mmlu Benchmark
and the blog post talks about it talks
about what the open llm leaderboard is
so for the ones of you who haven't seen
or heard a bunch of you who haven't seen
or heard about it it's a hiking face
leaderboard and with all of the
open source available uh llms on hiking
phase and those are evaluated against a
standard set of Benchmark from eluth AI
called eval homness and in there we see
that currently Falcon for example is the
overall best model we have dilemma
models in there but we can also scroll
down onto to smaller models where we see
llama alpaca 13b7b and there are a bunch
of more models and it basically should
help you get started okay which model
should like I pick two to fine tune or
to use for my application and what
assume and what is super cool about you
that it's a basically a community effort
so if you trained a new model or if you
want to add a new model to the
leaderboard you can basically submit it
here uh the only requirement is that the
model is available on the hiding face
Hub and then you define basically your
revision and then the model is run on
the hugging phase cluster with the same
set with the same set than all of the
other models which makes it basically
comparable and I think that's exactly
what the the blog post is about that you
always need to be careful about when
like reading papers or seeing benchmarks
since it seems that everyone is doing
kinda the same but different so for
example for The mmlu Benchmark there are
three different implementation of the
stage Mark and all of those three
different implementation
have different results for the model so
the the original mmlu Benchmark from
Berkeley creates different results than
the mmlu part mmlu part from the
extension and there's also like the
third implementation from illu Frei and
everything is basically documented and
if we we check
um
the differences so we can see for
the
Llama yeah here we can see like the top
llama model so the high invest team has
used all of the basically free mmlu
implementation mmlu implementation
um the top models against and here we
can see that on the helm mmlu and the
original one from Berkeley's llama uh
basically stays the best model and on
the mmlu from harness which is like
coming from illusion which was also the
one used on the open llm reward we can
see that
um Falcon is outperforming in llama and
everything exactly documented was the
difference between all of those how are
they prompted what is the diffusion how
many future examples are used
um I think it's like if you are
interested in like really how Ellie how
llms are either want to see okay what's
the difference then like definitely
check out the block uh highly
recommended
and then I think also since the last
time uh the open llm leaderboard got a
bit of an hidden extended view so
normally when you open the leaderboard
out of space you'll end up The llm
Benchmark light which has basically the
evil basically the illegal hard so now
an extended view which has an additional
column for the type so if the model is
already a fine-tuned model so
instruction models for example are
fine-tuned model and there are
pre-trained models uh which are not yet
fine-tuned we have a column for licenses
so that way you can like make sure okay
is the model I saw on the the top
performing
Benchmark is it usable for commercial
use cases and if we check for the best
average model we can see okay Falcon is
under Apache too but for example if
we'll get the Llama 65p it's under
another license which we know switch we
know that metaei has measural use for
for the model we also have a new column
for parameters which makes it easy for
you to also search and filter for okay
which which model size can I run and can
I use for my application we have column
for the the lights on the hiking face
Hub and then again the similar columns
we have from the
um first tab basically
basically
and so at the top of the leaderboard is
uh still uh Falcon 40b right and I know
we're getting us on our requests uh from
customers on how to deploy it
um so what are the the best options
today if you want to uh to deploy Falcon
40b on your own sort of endpoint
yes so let's go to the Falcon fee uh
model card so that's basically where you
can start when you want to to deploy and
if you go to deploy we currently have
like inference endpoints Amazon search
maker and srml and I think we are now
going to show you how to deploy it with
inference endpoints which is with
inference endpoints which is our manage
sus run the infrastructure for you which
is a lot for four five and 40D then
there's also uh the Amazon search maker
way which we're also going to show you
how to deploy the instructor Falcon
model into your AWS account and then
there's also HTML we are currently
working with SO2 to enable it so if I
would go to Azure it would basically
show OKAY model currently not available
currently not available
[Music]
already create the endpoint but what we
want to do now is since I have access to
a100s which which you can also request
if yours that are not having the quota
and we Deploy on the a100 additionally
we want to make sure that we have in
eight quantization enabled since the
FICA 40b model would be too big to fit
on a single a100 a single a 180
gigabytes so quantization needs to be
enabled and then when we click create
and now the input is created which
should take around five to ten minutes
since we need to download the model
start the instance and also make sure
the model is loaded and four or five can
four DB it takes quite a while to to
load the model into memory while that's
done we can look at how you would do
this with sagemaker going with sagemaker
going back model car we can also go to
deploy and into Amazon sagemaker and
here we get a code snippet for how you
could deploy the model to sagemaker so
basically what you could do here is copy
it put it into your Jupiter python
script where you have your AWS
credentials available and then run it
and the model will be deployed I already
prepared a notebook for it it's
basically an example we have created how
to deploy
llms to to sagemakers so
um we have created with AWS a new hiking
face container for deploying large
language models and the container is
based on the text based on the text
generation infrared we have a hiding
phase and it can be used to deploy
basically any open source llm model
including stockholder plume GPT Neo X
llama models T5 and all of the the other
models basically and what is super cool
about text generation inference that it
handles all of the heavy lifting for
running error lamps for us meaning it
includes tensor parallelism so it
includes tensor parallelism so if my
mobile view we automatically shot it
before loading it and then Distributing
it on the gpus you have available we
wrote special optimized Transformers
code for inference including flash
attention for example so if you're
running newer gpus you can benefit from
flash attention to reduce your memory
needed to to run large generation we
have support for quantization we have
continuous batching support allows us
basically or you to to get the maximum
throughput through
um through the application and then a
lot of additional features what is super
cool and definitely promising is the
watermarking features that you could
enable watermarking enable watermarking
which enables you to see okay what's the
code or the text generated by an llm or
not so that's that's definitely
interesting as well
okay what we need to do to deploy our
model we need to install the stagemaker
SDK that's basically used to to create
our endpoint and then the first thing is
to to set up our permissions for the
ones of you you haven't followed once of
you you haven't seen stage Vehicles so
um that's basically a code snippet to
gather permissions to be able to deploy
resources on the AWS cloud and then as
mentioned before we created this new
hiking phase llm container and here we
are going to use uh utility called get
hanging face llm image and where we
specify the version currently we are
going to use 0.8 and then we get back
our image URI which is pointing to our
deep learning container
and then
um similar to what we have seen in the
snippet we are going to use the
eigenface model we Define we Define the
instance type the G5 12x large instance
so not an a100 but we are still going to
deploy the 4db mode.g5 12 big slash
instance comes with four Nvidia 810 gpus
so we are going to split our model on
all four gpus and we Define our number
of gpus for the tensor parallelism and
then we also set an initial Health
checkout based on initial Health
checkout basically trying to run a super
big model it takes some time to start
the container please wait five minutes
before trying to see if the model is
available and then we have our model
configuration where we say okay that's
the high invest model ID and we have our
numbers of gpus and then also something
with check generation inferences we need
to tell the solution basic basically
before what is the maximum input length
and the maximum
um total tokens generated that's
basically there to help
um to award basically to help you avoid
any out of memory issues so if you are
familiar with gpus gpus you probably
have civil Cuda out of memory issue and
by using those boundaries uh you can
basically secure okay if any customer is
using your instance they cannot generate
more than four here for example 2048
token that basically avoids any out of
memory issues for your endpoint of
course first you need to make sure if
the values are correct so before I use
are correct so before I do that you you
validate those values so for example if
we use stockholder which has a context
length of 8 000 tokens we could set the
Max total length to four four thousand
token for example and then validate okay
is 4 000 enough to not run out of memory
or is it um should we decrease it or
maybe you want to keep it low on on
purpose just to I don't know
um but that way you can basically
configure your endpoint also if you
would like to use the quantization
feature We have basically enabled
through the UI uh in in inference
endpoints you can Define it here and all
of the the the
um file you can find on the text
generation inference GitHub repository
um then we need to like create our high
invest model class instance which is
basically a configuration holding our
AWS permissions the image and our config
and then we can run the dot deploy
method which creates our endpoint I have
done this already shortly we've already
shortly before our five to ten minutes
so we can like try our model
um here under the Run inference section
you can also see all of the hyper power
meters you can use for generating so you
can set the temperature you can set the
siege to make sure that you can like
reproduce your Generations you can set
stop tokens so if you want your model to
stop on a certain token you can define
those
um everything document I think we can
like share the link in a bit in a minute
again and now we can like test our model
and so what can I do in Toronto
and our model says there are many things
to do in Toronto some popular
attractions include the site directions
include the CN tower tops maybe I'm
missing some parameters
um that's where we can try to add our
parameters and increase the Max total
Max new talks to make sure that we get
the full suggestion from our models so
let's try again this time I ask what can
I do in Toronto give me free tips to be
a bit more specific and the free tips
are visit and the free tips are visit
the c ending structure in the Western
Hemisphere
not sure if that counts when looking at
New York maybe that counts for for
Canada we can explore the Distillery
District and check out the Royal Ontario
Museum awesome
and what is super cool about the the
Falcon 40b instruct model it is also
trained on conversational uh meaning
that we could easily create a chatbot
using trading so I prepared some small
little creative application which has
basically the chat interface and uses
our model to send requests to so we are
still using our sagemaker endpoint Edge
maker endpoint and create an application
and now we can start asking something
about AWS
I want to make sure it's English okay
what is Amazon sagemaker
and
what do we get back
Amazon sagemaker is a fully managed
platform that enables developers and
data science learnings quickly I guess
that's correct and then it provides a
range of tools and services including
pre-build algorithm pre-trained models
and a fully managed environment for
training and deploying models Amazon's
Age Maker also integrates with other AWS
services such as S3 ec2 S3 again to
provide a complete end-to-end solution
for deploying machine learning models
awesome
okay and then do you think we just need
to make sure that we stop our instance
again since sagemakers not yet having
Auto scaling to zero for GPU instances
and I think that's cool
looking at our endpoint our endpoint
what we can waiting for the model to be
started
all right we did it right on time 30
minutes on the money thank you so much
Philip there are a few questions uh out
there that I haven't answered yet in the
chat
um so one was
um do we know what the context window
for Falcon 7 billion is yeah
yeah so far both have uh 2048 as the
contacts member so certainly not that
big
nice and then another question was
um what is our best option for fast
inference and the question was about
like which instance but I know the
instance is not the only parameter like
quantization can play a part in it so
what would you say is the best setup for
for fast inference I think it really
depends on how much resources you have
available so there are like always
different things to optimize when you
like want to achieve faster latency
um definitely if you have like access to
currently h100 or a100s that's like the
East hundreds that's like the ECS like
way to use the best hardware you get
some performance improvements compared
to like older generation hardware and
then using tools like text generation
inference or Optimum to to optimize your
model meaning you can like as Jeff
mention uh quantize the model you can
use a faster or better implementation
for kernels so for example flash
attention is something less attention is
something where generation models we
also seen new ways on for the attention
mechanism so there's like the default
one is multi-headed tension but we see
new models like Falcon using multi-query
attention which also reduce the memory
needed for a generation which allows you
to have like bigger batch sizes so it's
not there's no I would say single answer
to it but I guess the best way it really
depends on what you have available if
you can upgrade your Hardware that's
probably a good step if you are not
already using an optimized inference
toolkit like text generation inference
then it's definitely a good way to to
get started so moving from like a fast
API trans API Transformers dot
generation to check generation inference
should give you like easily a 2X speed
improvements for all of the
optimizations we are doing and then if
you are like I would say experience and
interest in like low level optimization
you can like look at me I try them to
write your own kernels to fuse
operations or or improve the modeling
code to have like a less copies between
like CPU and CPU like CPU and GPU
that's awesome thank you so much
um maybe another last couple questions
uh so shritran was asking will hiking
face offer instant service in the future
like Lambda AI
and I think we we already kind of do
know like we now have like spaces who
has like Hardware upgrades where you can
like select CPUs gpus we have persistent
storage we have support for container
meaning that you theoretically could
create a space with a GPU and a
persistent space to run your Jupiter
notebook and then uh stop it if you
don't need it you can make your space
private Q space private so you can only
organization or your user so I think
it's it's already doable
and then I had a question about uh from
metia but are you planning to make
leaderboards according to language as
well that's that's a great question uh
we just added a bunch of features uh to
the leaderboard which Philip shows so
you can easily see the license the
popularity it's relaxed Etc uh I think
languages would require some specific uh
sort of benchmarks so definitely a
question that you should ask in the
community tab of the leaderboard space
where you can ask questions through the
uh uh to the spaces uh creators and the
community
cool well I think uh I think that's
going to be it for this uh show uh thank
you so much everybody for tuning in this
is of course recorded and we'll make it
to our YouTube channels where our
previous shows uh are living today
thanks so much Philip for the great demo
now it's up to you to deploy your own
Falcon 40 billion large language model
until next time
bye
yeah